>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, D.C.
>> Thank you very much.
I now have the pleasure
of introducing our
next keynote speaker,
Professor Jane Ginsburg.
She will be talking about
the most moral of rights,
the right to be recognized
as the author of the work.
Jane really needs
no introduction
but I will give you a brief one.
She is the Morton L.
Janklow Professor of Literary
and Artistic Property Law at
Columbia University School
of Law and Faculty Director
of its Kernochan Center
for Law, Media and the Arts.
I think she's been extensively
quoted on moral rights
so we are very, very pleased
to have her here today.
She's also my former
copyright professor
so I'm really excited
to have her as well.
Thank you.
With that I'll turn
it over to Jane.
[ Applause ]
[ Silence ]
>> Thank you very much Karyn
and I'm honored to be introduced
by a former student
and thank you very much
to the Copyright Office
and to George Mason
for having invited
me to give this talk.
The French revolutionary
legislator, Le Chapelier,
famously declared of all
properties the most sacred,
the most legitimate,
the least attackable
and if I may say the most
personal is the right the author
has in the fruits of his labor.
Descending from those rhetorical
and foreign heights I can affirm
that the most moral, the most
intuitive author's right is the
right to be recognized as
the creator of her works.
In fact most non-copyright
experts,
in other words ordinary folk,
think that authors
do enjoy the right
to be credited for their works.
Of all the many counterintuitive
features of U.S. copyright law,
and they abound, the lack
of an attribution right may
present the greatest gap
between perceived
justice and reality.
Even entities whose relationship
to copyright is ambivalent
for example Creative Commons,
make attribution a default
in their parallel
copyright universe.
Another example, many who lack
enthusiasm for paying authors
such as many online
platforms, pick your favorite,
query who needs money when
free distribution gives authors
great exposure.
Exposure however implies
credit for the work
and of course we have assumed
an international obligation
to credit authors.
The United States I believe is
the only country including among
common law countries not
to include attribution
rights in its copyright law.
Whether or not we can get
away with non-implementation
of Berne obligations
it is not a good thing
to be an international scofflaw.
Before I address the positive
law and future prospects
for moral rights in the United
States let's consider some
arguments for why our
copyright law should not include
enforceable attribution
rights and I will say
that I'll invoke three reasons,
one theoretical and
two practical.
The theoretical one one
might put under the rubric
of post-modernism
that attribution rights
overvalue authorship,
that they are a vestige
of the romantic conception
of authorship and
since we don't believe
in that anymore we
shouldn't believe
in attribution rights either
and there are variations
on that theme with which
I imagine you're familiar.
The second argument I'll call
the slippery slope argument,
that is attribution rights might
be okay but they will lead us
to integrity rights and we
don't want integrity rights
because among other things they
limit other authors' creativity
or for that matter the leeway
that producers enjoy
to revise works.
Now how do we get from
that slippery slope?
It's actually not the right
of attribution, it's the right
to prevent false attribution
that can lead to
integrity rights.
Think of the Monty Python case
that Peter Yu evoked
earlier this morning.
There the right to prevent
association of the name
with a work that Monty Python
didn't create because it was
so very much altered was
rendered enforceable briefly
under 43(a) -
[ Background Noise ]
[ Laughter ]
>> All right, of course we
have a little Dastar problem
that we'll evoke
later but I think
that analytically the right
to prevent false attributes,
not actually a moral right even
though many common law countries
include that in their
moral rights provision
because the right to prevent
false attribution is the right
to prevent the association
of your name
with the work you didn't create.
What moral rights are about is
the association of your name
with the work you did create.
Nonetheless if you're
going to have both sides
of the coin then you can see how
the argument towards integrity
rights gets constructed.
The third argument is
the most practical of all
which is it's simply
too difficult
to implement an attribution
right in practice.
Think of the mess in our current
case law about who is an author
and that's even without
the prospect
of having an attribution right
for actual creators regardless
of whether or not
the work is for hire
so you have the multiplicity
of potential authors,
how are you supposed to
recognize all of them,
how are you going to decide
which ones should be recognized
even if you could recognize all
of them that would end
up meaning tiny print
or endless film credits
that nobody looks at anyway
so it's not going to
do authors any good.
Now I think that
there are some answers
to the practical objections
that I will address in the rest
of this talk so let me
first start with the sources
of attribution rights.
Some of these have
been already evoked.
There are international norms.
There is the current state
of U.S. copyright law,
VARA and copyright
management information.
I've put in brackets various
private ordering solutions.
Can everybody see the slides?
And I believe there will be a
panel this afternoon talking
about private ordering
solutions and then I'll talk
about potential sources
in the U.S. copyright law
for the attribution right.
Starting with international
norms.
Daniel and others have already
evoked Berne Article 6bis
and that includes the right to
claim authorship of the work.
Now for reasons that will
become apparent I think
that there is a more important
source from U.S. point of view
of attribution rights and that's
Berne Convention Article 10.
This is the quotation
right that provides
that it shall be permissible.
So this is not an
option to states to allow
for quotation rights, this
is a direction to allow
for quotation rights subject to
a variety of conditions provided
that they're making these
compatible with fair practice
so their extent does not exceed
that justified by the purpose.
This text precedes Article
9(2) in the three-step test
which echoes some of
these considerations.
Most importantly
however where use is made
of the works mention shall
be made of the source
and of the name of the
author if it appears thereon.
So if you're copyright law
includes quotation rights
which it is supposed to
then there is an obligation
to include the name of the
author if the author appears
on the source of the quotation.
So a couple of questions.
First of all the three-step test
doesn't say anything explicit
about attribution rights.
What's the relationship
between 10(3) and 9(2)?
I would say that 9(2)
does not override 10(3).
10(3) is more specific and
it's apparent when one goes
through the drafting history
of the various iterations
of the Berne Convention that the
three-step test was not intended
to override the obligation to
mention the name of the author
in the quotation right.
I could also point out that the
third step does not unreasonably
prejudice the legitimate
interests of the author.
It's fully compatible with
an attribution obligation.
Of course one could say that
not crediting the author
unreasonably prejudices the
author's legitimate interest
but there's still a problem
within the Berne Convention
which is Berne does not
define who is an author
and in fact there are reasonable
arguments although there is
reasonable disagreement
that the question
of who is an author is left to
national legislation and so work
for hire is not necessarily
incompatible
with the Berne Convention.
If that is true then that could
mean that the beneficiaries
of these mandatory attribution
rights would be limited
to nonemployee authors.
Now, TRIPS has been
mentioned a couple of times
that are the moral rights
in the Berne Convention not
enforceable through TRIPS.
Here's the text that says so and
that's how come we have managed
to get away with not actually
implementing article 6bis
but I would like to argue that
the attribution obligation
through article 10(3) is not
a right derived from 6bis
and since the carveout is 6bis
and rights derived therefrom
if the attribution obligation
that accompanies the
quotation right is not derived
from 6bis it's enforceable
through a WTO dispute
resolution proceeding
and so takeaway number
one from this talk,
the attribution right is
enforceable in the context
of the quotation right
and I would be delighted
if some government,
France or otherwise,
would like to bring an action
against the United States
[laughter] for nonenforcement
of that enforceable obligation.
>> We are not encouraging
that however [laughter].
>> Yes, Karyn and I had
a few back and forths
about the description
of this talk.
The version that is
in the brochure is a little
more vigorous than the original,
well not my original but the
Copyright Office's original
description and Karyn
wanted to make sure
that the Copyright
Office was not tarred
with my attribution
radicalism [laughter].
>> We are in full compliance
with our international
obligations.
[ Laughter ]
>> Okay, now as I mentioned
United States is an outlier not
only with respect to those
suspect civil law countries
but also with respect
to common law countries.
Every common law country has
an attribution obligation
in connection with copyright
exceptions such as fair dealing
which is not quite fair use
but there's some similarities
and some other copyright
exceptions as well subject
to a reasonableness proviso
but nonetheless everybody
else has such an obligation.
I'll also point out that
the European Union has not
harmonized moral rights
but in the Orphan Works
Directive there is a provision,
Article 6(3) that
requires the name --
, including the name
of an identified author
if the work is disseminated
under the EU orphan
works regime.
So that's the international
landscape,
how about in the United States?
As you can see I don't think
much of VARA and I'm going
to explain why I don't think
much of VARA for this purpose.
Now Section 409(b) is
interesting because it does say
that the author's
name shall appear
on the registration
information however
that probably means
the statutory author
and therefore this
is not a source
of attribution information
for nonemployee authors
and then the other
possible locust
for attribution rights is
copyright management information
so let me talk about both
VARA and section 1202.
So the definition of a work of
visual art is extremely narrow.
There are very, very few
works that actually qualify
for attribution rights
and probably the most
significant limitation for works
that potentially qualify is
the requirement with respect
to photographs that they be
a still photographic image
produced for exhibition
purposes only.
I don't think that
such a category exists.
It didn't exist in 1990.
Maybe that has been created
for purposes of compliance
or qualifying under
VARA but it's a sort
of a strange category and
in any event would be --
, the image would be
protected only to the extent
that it fell within
this category.
Any additional images if they
didn't disqualify the photograph
entirely would in any event
not be covered by VARA
and this becomes clear
when you then look
at the scope of protection.
You have the right to claim
authorship of that work
but it has to be a work
of visual art, a very,
very narrow category, to prevent
the use of his or her name
as the author of any work
of visual art which he
or she did not create but that's
not a general false attribution
provision because
it only applies
to putting the author's name
on another "work of visual art"
so very narrow in application
and with respect to the tie-in
between attribution and
integrity again it's limited
to that very small
category of works
so this plays out as follows.
There's no attribution right
for any work that doesn't come
under the narrow
definition of VARA.
If the author's name
is put on an artwork
that she didn't create
but it doesn't fall
within the narrow category so
it's not a photograph produced
for exhibition purposes only
for example there's no right
and of course there's no claim
for the reputation harming
distortions of the work
if the work doesn't qualify
as a work of visual art
so it's a tiny, tiny universe.
Is there -
It's a tiny universe that
might have bad ripple effects
as a result of the
Dastar decision.
This is the case that all moral
rights advocates love to hate
for reasons that I think Peter
Yu has already made clear
but let me add one more.
There is a suggestion in
Justice Scalia's opinion
of a preemptive effect that the
only affirmative attribution
rights that we have in the
copyright law are in VARA
and well if Congress had
intended to have anything more
than that anywhere else in the
law that would be superfluous
so a law should not
be interpreted
as being superfluous even
though if you thought of this
as a Venn diagram you would have
what VARA covers is like a pea
in a watermelon so the ripple --
, to argue that the
fact that there are --
, that there's a tiny
shred of attribution rights
in VARA somehow that means
that there can't be
attribution rights anywhere else
in any other law is I
think sort of pernicious
so that's another reason to
deplore the Dastar decision.
All right, let's turn now
to copyright management
information.
The locust for this is
another international treaty
but the WIPO copyright
treaties post-date TRIPS
so their norms are
not enforceable
through TRIPS our compliance
is a matter of goodwill,
of course we totally
comply but there's no --
, we can't be hit over the
head if we don't comply
and indeed one could argue that
we don't comply because the text
of the WIPO Copyright Treaty
Article 12 and the equivalent
in the WPPT, well actually
never mind the WPPT,
just stick with Article 12,
the standard is this
double knowledge standard
which as we will see is
problematic but if one knows
that the removal or alteration
will enable facilitator, conceal
and infringement of any
right covered by this treaty
so the new rights in the
WCT or the Berne Convention.
The rights in the Berne
Convention include the right
of attribution so
under the WPPT removal
of copyright management
information that leads
to a violation of the
attribution right is actionable
but if you look at our text --
, I'll just move ahead
for a moment, the standard
for our text is having
reasonable grounds to know
that it will induce,
enable, facilitate
or conceal an infringement
of any right under this title
but we don't have an attribution
right under this title apart
from tiny, tiny VARA so that
means that there is a disparity
between the scope
of the obligation
in the WIPO Copyright Treaty
and the way we have implemented
that obligation in
U.S. copyright law.
The mere fact of denying
attribution through removal
of copyright management
information does not suffice
to make out a violation
of our provision.
So what does make out a
violation of our provision?
A few questions that the
courts have grappled with,
what is copyright
management information,
where must it appear and
the knowledge problem.
There had been some dispute
about whether copyright
management information includes
-- , is only digital information
or is any identifying
information
as set out in the statute.
I think the majority trend,
the overwhelming majority trend
today is that it's not limited
to digital information.
The text after all says
including in digital form,
well including implies that it
also covers not in digital form.
What's helpful here is that the
statute lists among elements
of copyright management
information the name of
and other identifying
information
about the author of the work.
However is that a
statutory author or is
that an actual creator?
We're back to that problem.
We've narrowed the zone of
beneficiaries of some CMI claim
if it's limited to
statutory authors,
however I think there
is a means,
if the Copyright
Office were so willing,
to include more actual creators
not just statutory authors
because the statute in number
eight gives the Copyright Office
the power to prescribe
other information
so the Copyright Office
could say creators regardless
of work for hire status.
The problem is that copyright
management information is
not obligatory.
Copyright management
information is applied
by the copyright owner
who may not be the author
and therefore there may not be
a total alignment of interests
and I think the way the
statute is written which says --
lists a whole bunch of
elements and says any of these,
that to me implies that
there is no obligation,
that you can't really read the
statute to say if you're going
to -- , you don't have to apply
copyright management information
but if you are going to imply
you must include
all eight of these.
I don't think, much as I
would like, I don't think
that that's an appropriate
reading of the statute.
Other questions that Section
1202 has given rise to which is
where is the copyright
management information?
Does it have to be embedded
in the copies themselves?
The statute doesn't say that.
Conveyed in connection
with is pretty broad and so
if for example as was mentioned
earlier the Creative Commons
licenses are explained
on the Creative Commons
website you could argue
that the combination of those
icons plus the explanation
together satisfies
the requirements
for copyright management
information.
Case law is divided on whether
just having a copyright notice
constitutes copyright
management information.
There's also questions
about where this
information should be placed.
In some respects it harks
back to the bad old days
of mandatory formalities and
where you place the notice.
You might lose your copyright
if you placed the notice
in the wrong place for
some decisions seem to lead
to a conclusion that if
you don't place the notice
in sufficient proximity
to the element
that you are claiming
copyright management information
for then it's invalid.
Now the hardest part
is the intense standard
because as I mentioned it's
a double intent standard.
Let's look at 1202(b)
although the reasonable grounds
to know the last part qualifies
both 1202(a) and 1202(b)
so you intentionally remove,
so there's a knowledge
element there,
or you know that
somebody else has removed
that copyright management
information
but that's not enough.
Then if the first knowledge
standard is met it is also
necessary to show that if you
distribute or publicly perform
and so forth the
altered or removed copies
of the works you're doing
that knowing that not only
that the management information
has been removed but also
that you have reasonable grounds
to know that that removal
or alteration will
induce, enable, facilitate
or conceal an infringement
of any right
and it can't conceal
an infringement
of an attribution right because
we don't have an attribution
right and that's where the
cases, many of the cases fail,
the attempts of authors
to invoke 1202 as a means
of protecting their-- ,
identifying them with the work
that it would have to be shown
that the distributor
not only knew
that the information had
been removed or changed
but that the distributor had
reasonable grounds to know
that that removal would
facilitate the infringement
of other -- , violation
of rights, other rights,
other economic rights.
Sometimes that can
be made out as
in the Agence France
Presse case against Morel
but there are a lot of cases
where it has not been possible
to make the link between knowing
removal or knowledge of removal
and reasonable grounds to know
that that will facilitate
a downstream infringement
of an economic right.
So that is a problem but I
have to say that we didn't make
up the double knowledge
standard.
That comes from the
WIPO Copyright Treaty
but what doesn't come from the
WIPO Copyright Treaty is the
linking to the violation of
an economic right as opposed
to the violation of
an attribution right
which is why I contend that as
enacted 1202(b) is of some help
but it could be better and
moreover it's not consistent
with the international text.
I don't know if Karyn wants
to say anything about that.
All right, so let's turn to
the more positive aspects.
What are the prospects for
moral rights in the U.S.?
And I've divided this
into without legislation
and then what if we
actually had a statute.
So without legislation, I think
that one strong possibility is
that the inclusion of
attribution should be --
, can already and should be
taken into account as part
of the first fair use factor.
It's not necessary to rewrite
107 to add an additional factor
but as part of the
nature and the purpose
of the use attribution
could be taken account of.
Now I have to acknowledge
that there is very,
very little case law on this.
There may be two cases
that consider that failing
to attribute cuts against fair
use but fair use is dynamic
and perhaps some
courts, particularly
if they were sensitive
to my slam dunk international
obligation argument might
interpolate an attribution
element into the consideration
of the first fair use factor.
I think there are things that
the Copyright Office could do
to make Section 1202
more effective.
I mentioned including
authors regardless
of their work for hire status.
I also think that the Copyright
Cffice could sponsor the
development of best practices
for identifying authors
and perhaps the next panel
will talk more about that,
that as mentioned earlier many
common law countries include a
reasonableness condition
as part of fair dealing
so what's reasonable could
be subject to development
through best practices or other
out of multiple stakeholder
forms of consultation.
That's the way Australia
does it.
Australia's statute delegates
to best practices so I think
that as part of an accompaniment
to a fair use inclusion
of attribution as part
of the first factor there
could be parallel development
of reasonableness standards
and also development
as a practical matter of
how are you actually going
to implement the information
about who is an author
to be credited.
And then there's the
question of waivers.
Although I've said
very bad things
about VARA there is one respect
in which I think VARA is
pretty good and that's
on the waiver standard and I'll
return to that when we look
at what a statute might include
but I think the Copyright
Office could also develop the
waiver issue.
There was a study that the
Congress directed the Copyright
Office to prepare in
connection with VARA
for how the waiver practice
was actually happening
but the study concluded that
there was almost no information
out there at the time that that
study was undertaken but perhaps
that could be revisited.
Okay, now let's call
this let's dream.
What if we had moral
rights legislation?
I think it has to answer
the following questions,
who are the beneficiaries,
what violates the right
and the waiver issue.
So in my world a human
creator regardless
of employment status
should be the beneficiary
of an attribution right.
I think that the monkey in
Borneo does not have copyright
or attribution rights but
human creators as opposed
to [inaudible] authors should
have attribution rights.
That doesn't tell you who
is a creator who is entitled
to attribution rights
but we do have case law.
It's not always coherent
and it's subject to lots
of criticism but there has
been an attempt in the courts
to develop the concept of who is
an author usually in the context
of joint works because somebody
comes out of the woodwork
and says I'm an author
too and not all
of that case law is laudable,
I'm thinking particularly
of [inaudible] but there is work
percolating from the courts.
Perhaps we could continue
to develop the concept
of who is an author
and then import that to
who gets attribution rights.
All right, scope, I think that
the duration should be the same
as for economic rights.
I do not think that attribution
rights should be perpetual even
though from a kind of consumer
protection point of view I think
that there's a consumer interest
in accurate attribution whether
the work is in the public domain
or not but as a matter
of copyright law I think
that the right should
be coterminous
with the economic rights.
The right would be infringed
by omitting the author's
name subject
to reasonableness requirements
and as mentioned earlier I think
those reasonable requirements
could be developed
through a multi-stakeholder
consultative process.
The last suggestion
I'm ambivalent about,
false attribution.
I said earlier that I think
that false attribution is
actually not a moral rights
issue and that common
law countries have
to some extent conflated
unfair competition issues
with moral rights.
The only reason I
would put it in his
because of the Dastar problem.
Peter Yu mentioned that
there's the broad reading
and there's the narrow reading
under the broad reading.
There may not be a 43(a)
claim for false attribution.
Lower courts have by and large
been taking a broader reading.
I think that while we're
dreaming the better approach
would be what Justin Hughes
has suggested which is
to "fix the Dastar gap by
amending 43(a)" to deal
with false attribution and then
I would take false attribution
out of a copyright
attribution provision,
but if we can't fix the Dastar
problem then this is better
than nothing but I acknowledge
that analytically it's a
different set of concerns.
And then waiver.
I said that I thought
that VARA was not bad
on the waiver provision
except for the very last part.
The very last part of VARA says
that one author's rights
waives everybody's.
That is very bad.
So I have rewritten this in
red to provide that a waiver
of rights made by one author
binds only that author
so the other -- ,
the co-authors,
do not lose their
attribution rights
but in other words I think
that that text is pretty good
and in our imaginary
statute could go in as such.
Finally remedies.
Again from VARA, VARA does not
make registration a prerequisite
either to bringing a claim or
to damages, statutory damages
for a violation of VARA.
I would import that into our
attribution right statute.
I think that the primary relief
would be injunctive relief.
The author wants her name
associated with the work and by
and large this would be
prospective but to the extent
that there might be
outstanding inventory
to the extent we still have hard
copies I think an appropriate
remedy would include
adding the author's name
to those already produced but
not yet distributed copies
and as for damages I think
it might be difficult
to prove actual damages
but statutory damages might
be an appropriate component.
How much those statutory damages
should be is another discussion
but I would be I think
favorable to having some element
of statutory damages and
I think we have some time
for discussion.
>> Yes, I want to start off
with just a quick question
about the Dastar case because
I think that's something
that people have
mentioned as the linchpin
of U.S. compliance
in some sense.
What would your view be
of whether the Dastar case
actually is a linchpin
so at the time that
we actually complied
with the Berne Convention
or said that we complied
with the Berne Convention Dastar
had not actually come down.
Would you agree that at
that time our moral rights
protections were strong
or would you believe that
they were actually still
somewhat weak?
>> I think when we ratified the
Berne Convention it was possible
to make a barely plausible
argument that our patchwork
which importantly included
43(a) suffice and I will say
that Jack Kernochan and I wrote
an article taking the position
that the patchwork
could be sufficient.
Now I will also point out that
we wrote that before the UK
and other common law countries
added explicit moral rights.
One of the arguments was the
United States doesn't need
to have moral rights
in the copyright law.
What counts is whether you
have a moral rights protecting
result, it doesn't matter what
the label is and I'm sympathetic
to that point of
view but a corollary
to that was just
look at the Brits.
They don't have any kind
of explicit moral rights.
They barely have any moral
rights at all and they're
in the Berne Convention
so if they can do it surely
the United States can do it.
That largely unspoken argument
then became somewhat less
persuasive when common law
countries did start enacting
explicit moral rights provisions
so that's another element
that perhaps has changed the
way one evaluates the question
between 1988 and
1989 and post Dastar.
>> And then just to follow
up on the post Dastar
points you had mentioned
that some district courts
are taking a broader reading
of the Dastar decision.
There is a debate in academics
as to whether you should
construe it broadly or narrowly.
Can you kind of give a
little bit more detail
as to how lower courts are
interpreting Dastar and whether
that affects how we
may use the Lanham Act
for compliance with
moral rights?
>> Okay well the first line of
defense which crumbled quickly
and Peter Yu alluded to it is
that DayStar concerned a work
in the public domain and you may
recall Justice Scalia's colorful
language about a
mutant copyright law
that the plaintiffs
here were end running,
the fact that they failed
to renew the copyright
in the motion picture and
they shouldn't be allowed
to get themselves a kind of
de facto extended copyright
by bringing the Lanham
Act into service
so the narrowest reading
would be regardless
of what the court said on
its facts this was a case
about a work in the public
domain and it doesn't prejudge
or determine the assessment
of a false attribution
or maybe even a non-attribution
claim with respect to a work
that is still under copyright.
Now that didn't fly at all
and I think it's pretty clear
that it didn't fly at all
because of what the
court said about origin.
A false designation of origin
does not mean the intellectual
origin of the work.
The court was very
clear about that.
It means that as Peter
said, I think it was Peter,
that it means the physical
origin, the producer,
distributor of the physical
goods, that's all that origin
in the Lanham Act means.
Well under that approach it
doesn't matter whether it's a
false designation of origin or
a non-designation of origin.
If origin doesn't mean
intellectual origin then
that kind of knocks the
Lanham Act out as a source
of attribution rights.
The broader reading still is
that some lower courts have
attributed rather broad
preemptive effect to Dastar
to conclude that you can't try
to work in attribution rights
or false attribution claims
under other theories
of law so that part,
the very broad interpretation
of Dastar means
that we don't have the
Lanham Act as a source
of attribution rights anymore
and we might not have some other
common law theories as a source
of attribution rights and
that wonderful patchwork
that was evoked in 1988 and
1989 is looking like maybe two
or three very ragged strips.
>> And with that I want to turn
it over to the audience to see
if we have any specific
questions to Professor Ginsburg
about how we might strengthen
moral rights of attribution
or whether we need to.
>> What I didn't
hear in your talk
about legislation was why
we should have legislation
implementing a right
of attribution.
Is it strictly because we agreed
to in the Berne Convention
or are there other reasons
affecting the public interest,
why the general public would
be benefited by adopting this?
>> I suppose the first answer is
we did assume an international
obligation and in so doing
Congress supposedly took the
public interest into account.
When we ratified the Berne
Convention we thought
that that was a good thing
for the United States
and the Berne Convention
doesn't allow reservations
so you can't say well the Berne
Convention is a good thing
except for Article 6bis or
for that matter Article 18
which we did not
initially implement either.
That was the provision that
requires states when they join
to restore the copyright
in works of foreign origin
that are still in copyright
in their countries of origin
than if they are
out of copyright
in the United States
they have to be --
, their copyrights
have to be restored
and of course there were a
certain number of works that fit
that bill because they were
published without a notice
of copyright, they went
straight into the public domain
or their copyrights weren't
renewed and so they went
into the public domain after 28
years which is much too short
under the Berne minimum period
of protection or in some cases,
in fact the Golan case
itself concerned works
which one they were
published their country
of origin was a country
that was not a member
of a copyright treaty with
us but Article 18 says
that when another country joins
the Berne Union then their works
have to get protected, so we
had an international obligation
enforceable through TRIPS
to restore the copyright
in Soviet works that had fallen
into the public domain
in the United States.
Now Congress made
the determination
that passing the burden,
ratifying the Berne Convention
was a good thing not just
for authors but for
the public and also
for the American economy as
a whole because even back
in the 1980s the ways we used
to make money by making cars
and steel and electronics
we weren't doing
that so much anymore but
we were certainly creating
and exporting an awful lot
of intellectual content
and so we had an interest beyond
the perhaps parochial interest
of authors in having very
good international protection
so I guess that would be my
first answer to the question
about whether attribution rights
are in the public interest,
I'd say at that highest level.
I would say also that
attribution rights are
in the public interest in part
for what some might consider
to be consumer protection
interests
that the public has an interest
in knowing who created this work
and that the author obviously
has an interest and that
that interest is not
simply a vanity interest.
I think that the Constitution
conceives of copyright
as creating an environment
that will encourage creativity
and being recognized for your
creation I think is very much
part of that environment
and so I would say
that public interest is one
that should be considered
to be deeply rooted not only
in our economic interest
but in our polity.
>> Any other questions?
>> Hi, Carrie Devorah, Center
for Copyright Integrity.
I was very excited
when you were speaking.
I'm thinking oh awesome how is
it nobody has gone after Google
for doing exactly the
violations you were talking
about should not be done?
I also wanted to raise a
point about David Slater,
the monkey photographer.
I've gotten to know him.
I would consider what David did
in what he's explained
to me as set design.
He worked for weeks with a
monkey to encourage the monkey
to become familiar so just
keep points on, a fact on point
but Google, look
what they've done.
They have walked away
with all of our works.
I took a picture of
a picture I just did,
sent it out to a
colleague of mine
but that picture has
now been taken from me.
I'm not dead yet, I'm
not life +70 so how is it
that Google has escaped the
liability of what you just
so wonderfully described
a liability existing for?
>> I think that question we
go to economic rights as much
as to attribution rights.
On -
[ Inaudible Speaker ]
Let me -- , get back to that
on the monkey [laughter].
I think there have been -- ,
I didn't mean to be flippant.
There have been a number
of variations of the story.
Some have given the monkey
more agency than others.
Under the maximal monkey
agency approach [laughter],
up there with the
Zika virus I think
that that does not qualify.
However in the variations
on the story
where the photographer
set the scene
and all the monkey did was click
the shutter there are a lot
of cases actually not only in
the U.S. but in other countries
where it's exactly
that scenario.
The photographer has set the
scene and somebody comes along
and pushes the button and
courts generally consider,
that is the person
who structured the image not
the person who pushed the button
who is the author of
the work but this gets
to the question fairly
raised if we're going
to have an attribution right we
had better know who is an author
and in many instances that's
not going to be too difficult
to figure out and in lots
of instances there are indeed
conventions about giving credit
if one thinks about the Writers
Guild agreements in such.
The fact that at the margins
it may be difficult to identify
who is an author is
not for me a reason
to deny attribution
rights altogether.
On the contrary I think
we need to work on coming
up with a reasonable
and implementable notion
of authorship and I do
think that digital media,
CMI is not limited to digital
media but digital media
in fact offer a lot
of opportunities
for robust author
identifying information.
>> Any other questions?
>> I was going to circle back
to this in RMI but I'm curious
when you were talking
about the AFP v. Morel case
and in connection with
the CMI information there,
do you favor a more
broad interpretation
or a more narrow one?
>> I think that the claim could
be made out in the Morel case
because what Agence
France Presse did was
to make the picture available
for other news entities
to then reproduce
and communicate it
so there you could show that
they had reasonable grounds
to know that there would be
a downstream infringement
but the facts don't always work
out with the downstream
infringement.
You wouldn't have to worry
about that if the removal
of the attribution were
itself an infringement
which is what the WIPO
copyright act says
but then the question
becomes can you fix that gap
between the international norm
and our implementation
of that norm.
Is it possible to fix
that without legislation
or would it be necessary
to somehow work
in the words attribution
in order to close the gap?
And I think it would be
nice if one could come
up with a creative way to close
the gap without legislation
because I'm not so
sanguine about legislation
but if we are going to have
legislation that's a clear
candidate and I invite people
to be creative in thinking
about how you can somehow
interpret section 1202
to make it consistent with
our international obligations
and of course there
there is no WTO action
because the TRIPS
Accord doesn't apply
to the WIPO copyright
treaties which came later.
>> I argued for AFP
in the Morel case
and my take is a little
different on the case.
First of all it was fascinating
but the jury had no
understanding at all
about the DMCA and I
mean that was very clear.
At the early part of it
there was no Morel name
on any of the artworks.
By way of background he posted
these, initially it was thought
that he was a citizen
journalist.
Somebody stole them,
a guy named Suero
so AFP initially takes
them off Suero's site
and lists it giving
Suero credit.
A few hours later they
find out it was Morel
and they always gave
Morel credit.
He was always in the tag.
It said AFP Morel or AFP Getty,
Morel as part of
the distribution.
There was never any time
that his name was removed
because his name
wasn't on anything.
It wasn't on the website.
It wasn't on his website either
so there was never any removal.
There was never any distribution
by AFP or its subscribers
or Getty without
attribution to Morel.
What the jury seemed
to have found
and again it was
convoluted because --
, well we don't have
to get that into it,
but it was that they
associated, it said AFP, Getty,
Morel which is standard
media information
for a source distributor
and photographer
and since he wasn't
affiliated it seemed it was
that misassociation
that was the basis
of the very small DMCA award
which was kind of odd for us
because there was
never any distribution
and the court also
specifically did not --
, they ruled against
the argument
that they originally made
because they originally
said this was going
to be a $180 million
dollar case.
We could see the
DMCA going downstream
and the court ruled not,
that the downstream users
were not going to be counted
as part of the DMCA damages.
>> I think that your account
of the facts illustrates why
it would be a really good idea
to develop standards
or best practices
that the Copyright
Office might endorse
for what is copyright
management information.
>> I think we have time for one
last question if we have any.
Well I think we're
just one minute out.
I guess my last question is
do you have any predictions?
You said you weren't
that sanguine
about the possibility
of legislation.
>> Well I think some of this
is in your hands [laughter]
and so I want to be sanguine
about what the Copyright
Office can do
because I think actually
there's quite a lot
that the Copyright Office
can do both enforcibly
and certainly morally
and I'm quite serious --
, I think I said there
were two takeaways,
one is that Article 10(3)
of the Berne Convention
imposes an enforceable
through the WTO obligation to
credit the author in the case
of the quotation
right and that many,
much of what we consider
fair use would fit
within the quotation right.
And therefore take
away number two
that court should start
developing as part of 107(1)
to take into account the
attribution to the author
if it was reasonable to
attribute to the author
and then the copyright office
can tell us what's reasonable
when it comes to
author attribution.
>> Well I want to take
this time once again
to thank Professor Jane
Ginsburg for her talk.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.